[Music]
chuck we got an emergency explainer we
got to do like right now oh wow
emergency emergence emergency emergency
there was an underwater volcano that
gave a tsunami warning to the entire
west coast of north america what's up
with that
okay sounds to me like a great movie
it does doesn't it but i don't know
anything about volcanoes but we do know
someone who does and that is natalie
starkey friend of star talk natalie
welcome back to the show hey hi neil hi
chuck secretary excellent
excellent your cosmo chemist i love that
on a business card uh author most
recently of fire and ice volcanoes of
the solar system you are the person we
need for this show okay and it's not a
show this is just an explainer we only
got a few minutes so apparently an
underwater volcano erupted recently tell
us what happened here yeah it was
massive this is the problem it's uh it
is currently now underwater previously
it was also above the waters there was
an island in you know the middle of the
pacific near tonga and uh it blew its
top and basically the whole volcano the
whole island has disappeared in that one
eruption of 10 megatons it was
absolutely enormous it created an ash
cloud that went up to 130 000 feet so
it's a really big event now that this
island although it has a name but did it
did it have inhabitants
no completely uninhabited it's one of
them not anymore
wow
i mean it it's appeared out of the ocean
a number of times and sort of been
eroded away by the ocean so it's always
kind of playing with that ocean level
quite a bit and so it's never been a big
island and but what's happened here is
that you know it's kind of it's been
inhabited by plants and things before
but no humans um but it's just a really
crazy setting it's a very very active
volcano and when it goes it goes really
really big so but natalie it's just it's
just it's just accidental that it's
underwater there are volcanoes
everywhere if it just happens to be
underwater it's not a special kind of
volcano is that correct no i mean a lot
of the volcanoes actually begin
underwater we have obviously volcanoes
on land and then we have volcanoes that
start on the base of oceans and grow
large enough to become you know a
volcano above the land you know like the
entire hawaiian island chain exactly
they're all under sea volcanoes that
then have become so large they've risen
above the sea so it happens all the time
now one of the issues is when you're at
that kind of level where you're a little
bit below the ocean and then sometimes
above the ocean is that the water from
the sea can infiltrate the you know the
vent of that volcanic which is under the
water and when you mix water with really
really hot magma you're going to create
what we call free atom magmatic
explosions which is what's happened here
magma mixing with hey okay
first of all watch your mouth young lady
second of all what the hell he gets
magmatic on star talk that's all right
what did you just say what what kind of
reaction so it's freato magmatic so this
is water and magma mixing so you've got
to remember this magma is that you know
a thousand degrees celsius or more and
if you put a little bit of water into
that what do you think is going to
happen you're going to have a massive
explosion and this is how you create you
just literally fracture rock and magma
into pieces and that's what no let me
tell you what i learned from you that
lava that hasn't come out of the volcano
yet is called magma is that correct yeah
exactly
i got that seat chuck i don't know what
i'm talking about with this eruption
there was there was no lava with this
eruption it just it didn't even get to
that stage it just completely exploded
that magma just completely exploded into
the sky so um yeah wow so how many how
many of these we have around the world
that we should keep an eye on i mean
loads of them within any year we have
maybe 50 or 60 you know volcanic
eruptions we don't always notice them
when they're very big like this and they
create a pressure wave that goes around
the world and we can detect that and we
can see it from space we saw you know
that huge ash cloud from space from
satellite imaging um you know it's a big
one you're going to notice it but most
the time we've got eruptions happening
that aren't particularly noticeable this
was just a very big one that created a
very big blast and tsunamis when you
have a pressure wave through earth you
guys measure that with all your sensors
but if you have a pressure wave in the
ocean that has different consequences
right yeah and actually so there's
there's two different kind of pressure
waves created when that volcano erupted
it literally just displaced the air so
we saw a wave travel through the
atmosphere of a pressure wave that was
created from that explosion but we also
think there was maybe tsunamis created
from the volcano itself collapsing now
we're still not sure because we haven't
been able to get on you know to that
location and have a look at what's
actually happening now it's all under
water so we can't really see but we
think
currently that the volcano collapsed
displaced water and that could have
created the tsunamis that we think have
happened but we're still waiting for
that ground data from all those regions
because tonga's been cut off um from
communications wait you don't know if
there was a tsunami that seems to me
that'll be obvious at least in the
movies it's kind of obvious when the
tsunami comes yeah we it seems like tong
was almost inundated with tsunamis and
we also saw big waves um you know
hitting the coast of america so for sure
um there were tsunamis emanating from it
but we don't know the cause at the
moment exactly we don't know whether um
it was the volcano itself collapsing to
create that you know that big wave
initially what else what else would it
be
it almost certainly is that um but it
could have been created from that
pressure wave initially um it's just you
know before we get that ground age it's
really hard all we can see from this
volcano is what we can see from space um
at the moment and we now have aircraft i
think from new zealand they're traveling
over to have a look at what's going on
and what they can see at the moment is
there was an island there and there's no
longer an island so whatever was there
has completely blown
so natalie it's one thing okay yes we
know you care about what might have
caused the tsunami but people affected
by the tsunami are not asking that same
question they just want to know
is the tsunami coming and how bad is it
going to be yeah so what what
measurements do we know of so far and
how long did it take for that wave to
get from
its location to the coast yeah so it
wouldn't have taken very long because i
mean tonga is quite a small i mean it's
the islands are spread out over a large
region but ultimately it's quite in a
small part and so that ash cloud
actually covered pretty much all of
tonga the ash cloud itself the extent of
it was the same size as the uk so it's
it's really really large as it came up
so the tsunamis that came out from from
that eruption um would have hit those
islands very very quickly it's very easy
to predict um kind of how how high those
waves are going to be and well sorry no
it's very easy to predict how fast
they're going to travel but not how high
they're going to be because that depends
very much on the local kind of
topography of the land on in the ocean
so
we know that you know we know when it
will get to certain places those waves
but we don't know how big those waves
were it seems now from evidence on the
ground that we're hearing from the
tongan government that um you know all
the coastal areas were inundated and a
lot of land and buildings have been
destroyed um and probably just to be
clear
you're dialing into star talk now from
the uk yes but many people listening are
americans and we don't know how big the
uk is you said the cloud was as big as
the uk can you give us a state that
resembles that oh a state in the u.s
goodness is it bigger than texas
that's what i want is a bigger
intestines because if it ain't bigger
than texas it ain't big it ain't big
we we have this thing in the uk where we
compare everything to wales and that's
going to mean even less to use unless i
know
right smaller than california i think
the egyptians not the mammalian whales
you mean whales the the the country
that's full of sheep and yeah on the uh
the western coast of the uk so not
helpful at all i realized
so it seems to me we i mean we've heard
about tsunamis in recent decades that
were caused by underwater
uh or or or earthquakes that would take
place underwater and this i guess
displaces water creates a wave so our
volcanic tsunamis less dangerous than
earthquake tsunamis they're not less
dangerous they're just less common so
it's much less common that a volcano
will collapse into the ocean or collapse
under the ocean and create you know push
water out of the way and create a
tsunami it does happen but it's it's not
particularly common but the earthquake
generated ones are much more common
obviously we saw that we've seen that
quite a lot um in the past uh but it
yeah i guess it was the what we call the
boxing day tsunami again i think that's
another british term i'm talking about
uh december 26th and there was a movie
about that
um and and that was a big big tsunami
that hit uh it wasn't okay
researchers have told us that um the uk
is about the size of alabama oh okay
interesting yeah so so so natalie is
this um do are volcanoes on earth as
interesting to you as volcanoes
elsewhere in the solar system yeah i
mean completely because we can study
them so much easier like you know even
this volcano which um scientists have
used as a case study for studying
volcanoes in space because it's so
inaccessible the only the main way we
study is by satellite which exactly is
exactly the way we study volcanoes in
space because we can only study them by
satellite we don't go there personally
so we can look at how this volcano has
erupted over time and how you know
plants colonize it over time and we can
compare that to what we see say on mars
and what might have happened in the past
on mars so the volcanoes on earth are
just brilliant because they give us this
testing ground we can get to them much
more easily but they allow us to compare
what we then see in space
but chuck you heard she said the plants
colonize it first then the europeans
colonize it then they enslave the plants
exactly that's how that how it goes
natalie do i remember some photos of you
with like volcano
outfits on
entering the calderas of of extinct
volcanoes or or or dormant volcanoes
am i picturing that correctly i know an
active volcano so i've worked
excuse me
yeah in in the caribbean i've worked on
active volcanoes you know where you're
literally standing next to this this
vent at a volcano that's roaring away
with all the gases and steams that are
coming out of it and and you know it's
an incredibly exciting environment to to
be in okay i have to channel chuck here
and say
not a place where the you find the
brothers
[Laughter]
you know there's there's common sense
and then there's black sense
which is even more
sensible it's even more sensible than
common sense
let's go into the caldera of that active
volcano won't that be fun
and then the answer is
have a good time
i'll meet you back at the cabana when
you're done
i'll be drinking a coconut when you get
that
so natalie
tell me um in your book which is which
is really the
an amazing clearinghouse of of
information about uh just volcanoes of
all kinds uh just remind us uh just
before we end here not all volcanoes are
hot
right and just just remind us how you
get a cold volcano because that's the
subtitle of your book fire and ice fire
and ice exactly so we we have what we
call cryo volcanoes so ice volcanoes and
actually there's possibly more ice
volcanoes in the solar system that are
active then we have hot volcanoes which
kind of seems mad because we have we
that's all we know on our own planet but
you know let's go out to somewhere like
enceladus or europa or you know pluto
but we find in these places volcanoes
made of ice so instead of rock we erupt
water or we erupt ammonia or
nitrogen like whatever these worlds are
made of and these are mostly moons i'm
talking about um we can erupt whatever
they're made of onto the surface and
that becomes their lava instead of rocky
lava or ash so yes so what causes the
the actual eruption on those
is it the same pressure i mean i call
volcanoes pimple popping on earth stop
stop it's like the earth just popped the
pimple chuck stop truck stop you know
got a little build up under here let me
get rid of it you know
what happens on these other planets that
ice becomes
the way i look at it is that actually
all volcanoes are doing the same thing
and they're releasing heat from inside
of that body so they just it's just a
way for a planet or a moon to cool
itself down they all have heat within
them that heat wants to move because of
physics it just wants to move to
somewhere colder and in doing so it will
you know erupt whatever the material is
that that planet or moon is made of so
wow and so just a matter of pressures at
any temperature right
yeah and and you know if you've got
liquid if you've got you know ice uh
water ice and you want to melt that you
don't need to heat it to as high a
temperature as you'd need to heat rock
to create lava so you just it's
different temperatures we're talking
about but we're still talking about heat
moving and moving material in the
process
and pressure
yeah yeah yeah good stuff all right well
we gotta call it quits there natalie
thank you for explaining like current
events to us and give me the full name
of that volcano oh no okay so it's hunga
tonga hunger
pie
it's the last bird i'm not too sure
about um but it's basically it's the two
names of what was the two islands that
then got connected with the volcano in
the middle so yeah i'm not sure if
you're familiar with uh the bugs bunny
cartoon but that's very bugs bunny
hunga
yeah that's why they're called looney
tunes that's a looney tunes bit right
there
i probably butchered the name for any
tongans and i apologized um how you know
it's probably not pronounced exactly
like and chuck should be apologizing but
he's a comedian so
well listen i put your names on this
show
every single time we're on so
welcome to the club
all right natalie it's always good to
know you're in arms reach of us when we
need emergency accounting of what's
going on on this planet and others so
thanks for being on star talk explainer
as always all right chuck always good to
have you man always a pleasure got neil
degrasse tyson another star talk
explainer keep looking up
[Music]